you know it's a commonly held
misconception that sex scenes are
sexy or like you know they're fun or
exciting or whatever they're not they're
like
they're so awkward and so like there's
there's so much other thinking
going on you know you're concerned about
what you look like what you're doing
what the other person looks like
what they're doing whether you feel
comfortable if they feel comfortable
cool i want to come to you
and you know i think the the the best
thing about ordinary people is normal
people is just about the
how ordinary they are and yet
extraordinary tell me about what really
spoke to you about connell the very
first time you read the script
um yeah i think from the first couple of
pages of i read the novel just as the
audition came in
and it's kind of one of those
um pieces of source material that i
became incredibly
scared of straight away because it was
very identifiable and i think when
something is identifiable you kind of
recognize yourself within it and go like
oh
yeah if i don't get this then maybe this
uh this career isn't for me and things
like that but i think it's because
identify with him i identify with the
situations he's been in and i also not
like i see my friends in him
you know i see people who i love and
care about within the kind of
capsule of him so um it was kind of
you know it was totally i just
recognized the kind of
heart and soul of them very quickly and
your
your chemistry with daisy is essential
to us believing in your relationship and
the world around you
how much rehearsing did you have to do
to develop your relationship and is
there such a thing as rehearsing too
much
um yeah i think um we
worked with the wonderful director lenny
abramson on the first block
and we didn't do a huge amount of say
like uh
like standard rehearsal like we kind of
spent about a week together
prior to it and talked about the
character and
very tentatively touch on scenes and
then very quickly run away from it
um but yeah it was i think it was more
so kind of
chance for me and daisy to meet
see each other um but we we had done a
chemistry read before it so i think
there was a kind of
understanding that we would work
together well and
i could not have asked for a a better
partner for that show
yeah it must have been really special
having michaela always on set
as director writer actor how did that
age or process
and understanding of the character in
the story
yeah it's dope it's obviously dope like
as actors um
often like so much of the the work
on like you do all the preparation work
you can before you turn up on set you
know you learn your lines you kind of
come up with ideas whatever
but i'd say like 60 of the time when
you're actually on set you kind of
you're kind of like
what are we actually trying to do here
and like what sexual sense of the scene
and
you know like everything's so bitty you
know like
it's hard to kind of always have a kind
of
anchoring in um where you are in the
story and what exactly
you're trying to do so it's an absolute
gift a dream to
have the kind of brainchild of
everything right there beside you and
like michaela's like look we we we all
we we all know what we know about
michaela she's an extraordinary person
but like
she's got a huge appetite for
collaboration and
for growing a story um as as we go so
you know there's a story that's on the
page there's a story
that you know we you know didn't read
through but that's a very different
story to
um what we actually came up with on set
and then even more different to what um
txt on television you know so like it
was it was an ongoing process but having
her
um it kind of just like allows those
moments when you really really are
like what is happening
how often did that happen how often
don't i mean to be fair i don't know if
that's more if that's down to my own
insufficiencies
or just like the everyday struggles of
an actor but like i mean it happens a
lot you know especially
a show that i may destroy you is not
like it's not a traditional format it's
not
unnecessarily linear timeline so
um it jumps about a lot and the
characters
have very intense you know hours and
then like time passes and
you know we have to fill in fill in the
in between bits
um and yeah that's part of our job but
it's great to have someone who's um
who's who's at least got an over actual
idea of of what she's trying to achieve
now i've met eater o'brien the movement
and intimacy coordinator who
both you and paul you both worked with
her
and i know how incredible she is tell us
about the difference it made to your
performance
having her on set paul and yeah i
like i suppose i find it hard to kind of
preface it with i i had
no understanding of what it was to work
on a set let alone
like in an intimate capacity that normal
people definitely
has within the story but so it's kind of
like the standard in which i
just associate is normal now
and which i think is actually really
healthy and because i i just can't
imagine
that process without a very clear
professional professional voice who is
totally focused on that one
like that that one part of the show and
and it kind of allows everyone else more
freedom it allows me and daisy to have a
direct line
to her and lenny and i think it just
opens up more
capacity for conversation i think
there's probably a stereotype that like
intimacy coordinators is like oh it's
not [ __ ] real or fresh or anything
like that and that's actually not what
you're
chasing and those situation definitely
like you you're actually looking for
to begin those things from a place of
comfort and
be as confident as you can be within
that and i think it was just so
wonderful and and intuitive with
how me and daisy like to work so i just
uh
i hope and i think we are seeing it um
becoming a more steadfast position on
sets now
i think it's it's vital to be honest
yeah papa
was your experience similar yeah totally
i
i couldn't agree more if one is like um
you know it's a commonly held
misconception that sex scenes are
sexy or like you know they're fun or
exciting or whatever they're not they're
like
they're so awkward and so like there's
there's so much other thinking going on
you know you're concerned about what you
look like what you're doing what the
other person looks like
what they're doing whether you feel
comfortable if they feel comfortable and
like
i feel like without um without an
intimacy coordinator you're really kind
of like heading out into the desert and
opening
hoping you don't starve you know like
it's it's wonderful to have someone
whose
total focus is on protecting that space
and like just like yeah it's just like
it kind of like like paul says it's not
about
interrupting the spontaneity or how
organic the um
the process is it's about like ring
fence in an area for you to
feel safe to kind of play and to do the
scene you know so you can actually like
focus on
what the scene that is written down is
and you can focus on the other person as
a character because you're not worrying
about whether
um they're feeling uncomfortable or
whether you're feeling uncomfortable you
know so it's just that sets the rules in
in a really clear way that allows you to
feel more relaxed
and and therefore makes it just for me
way easier to do the job because i've
i've
had instances before where where we
haven't been given that kind of space
and like
there's so much kind of like subcut
there's some conscious
communication that you're hoping is
happening but you don't want to be
misinterpreted or
whatever you know so yeah he is amazing
she's like
a completely unique personality um
she's got a fantastic way of working and
of putting people at ease and she like
gets involved herself you know so you're
never gonna feel like an idiot because
she's gonna
she's gonna make an example of herself
before before you have to
[Music]
you